he's Mark Cuban the Mavericks owner
joining us on the program how's morale
mark hey hanging in there how are you
holding up Dan I'm doing okay so what
are you what are you doing are you able
to get out of the house
no I mean well I mean I could get out of
the house out of the house it like heads
in the backyard and fortunately I got a
hoop up so my ten-year-old and I get out
there and play horse and you know shoot
around and you know try to be normal so
it hasn't been too bad now this isn't
the house you had like 20 years ago
what is oh you stayed in that house same
house yeah yeah creatura have it and
it's it one room the old wiffle ball
court room still has no furniture so we
play wiffle ball and family dodgeball in
there and it broke into a few things but
yeah so it's still my wife is definitely
decorated it but it's not what normal
people would do
it's like Warren Buffett Warren has been
in that house for decades yeah I've
lived in two houses over the last I
don't even want to say how many years so
yeah I'm comfortable what's the coolest
thing in your house the trophy look at
right now as we speak
that baby is beautiful how often do now
do you have somebody who cleans up in
your hand like who dust off the NBA
championship trophy me just you like
once every two years I send it out to
get cleaned just to give it that extra
shine polish you how often are you
communicating with the commissioner um
not very often at all I mean his hands
are full so there's not a whole lot I
can contribute he's doing everything he
can but we get pretty much daily updates
from the league office what do you think
is there a drop-dead date no no
everything's on the table there are no
rules you know the bad news is there are
no rules the good news is there are no
rules and so everything's on the table
you don't know how you know I'm not
positive I think things are going to
turn out you know better than we think
sooner than we think obviously was still
a lot of disruption but I think we'll
have to look and see you know what
happens with television television
viewing is way up you know people are
watching shark tank we're having our
highest ratings in years
you know how long will that be sustained
you know is it now a great time to put
on a game with no fans the minute we're
able to we'll see you know it's it's
things are different and so we'll adjust
accordingly what kind of options are on
the table though when it comes to the
regular season and the postseason well I
don't want to speak for the league but
just you know talking out loud here just
hypothesizing I think we can play five
games to get guys back in the groove and
then go into the playoffs and maybe make
the first round five games instead of
seven and then just have and play it out
from there
depending on when we start obviously you
know talking to the people I know and
everybody thinks they know the guy or
the woman right I think that we we start
to really come out of this in six weeks
and that's where you know instead of you
know not leaving your house you can
leave your house and instead of
gathering limited to ten people you can
go to 25 people and that gives us a
chance to play a game probably without
fans without an audience but that said
if there's one thing that's going to
bring the country back to some level of
normalcy and get people's blood going
again in a positive way and get people
excited it's going to be sports and the
NBA is incredibly well positioned to to
be the sport that drives you know the
recovery and so I think the you know the
Commissioner is looking for us for us to
lead and to set an example and to be
that league that gets people you know
excited again if he gets few people
rallying around their teams because the
minute we put on that first game even if
it's an exhibition game everybody in
there brother even if you kind of it'll
be kind of like the Super Bowl I'm not
saying that many people are watched but
you know half the people don't even
watch for the game they watch for the
ads and a half time and I think our
first game you know when we come back
it'll be the same way just because
people want to rally around the flag
they want to feel some sense of normalcy
what was your reaction when you found
out in real time that Rudy Gobert had
tested positive I don't find out till
later it was you know it was shocking um
but not surprising you know you don't
want to see anybody you know hit with
this but you know basketball players
celebrities whoever Tom Hanks we're not
immune from any
um you know viruses don't care and so I
I was shocked but I wasn't surprised
well we're watching you react in real
time when the commissioner said we're
going to you know postpone stop play did
you see yourself eventually and how you
reacted yeah I'll be a meme for the firm
or you know not enough Cubans going
crazy right your cat just meow do you
know they're Cubans we're talking to
Mark Cuban the Mavs owner how are you
dealing with this as a businessman I
mean every business is different um
obviously it's really a struggle for
most people and I'm most concerned about
employees that get paid by the hour
I mean before all they're hit just
living paycheck to paycheck you know not
knowing how many hours or you know how
things were going to turn out that's
that was brutal then it's unimaginable
what everybody's going through now and
so we're continued to pay our folks as
if nothing happened um we're trying to
do that I'm trying to get as many of my
other companies that I'm involved in but
may not own to do the same we're
possible
and then there's also some companies
that have that are doing well because of
this you know if you sell toilet paper
if you sell consumables you know our
company dude wipe is killing it you know
you if you want something more you know
more clean than toilet paper by dude
wipes and people are and you know and
people who sell food as people fill up
their pantries um and so we're trying to
get them down you know rather than just
putting the money in the pocket hire as
many people as possible and and just try
to do the right thing and you know and
hopefully everybody out there that's
involved in a small business will
immediately go to sba.gov and start
applying for emergency loans so that you
can try to retain all your employees
it's not going to be easy these are
crazy times and we'll see what happens
with what legislation is passed today
hopefully but you know everybody's just
got to try to do what they can do have
all your players have been tested I
can't comment on that but nobody has
anything and I haven't been tested I
know none of our managers you know none
of our staff that I'm aware of has been
tested we haven't had anybody showing
any
so there there's no reason for them to
be and it's just such a crazy time and I
know that we sound selfish when we say
boy we want to have games come back but
I just think there's only so long you
can watch the news or listen to the news
in write I know the NFL has been
criticized by some people that you know
should they be continuing business as
usual here yes what do you think yes yes
look we turn on the news and there's
people doing their job from home and
that gives us a sense of normalcy the
minute we turn on ESPN or CNBC or
whoever and there's nobody there that's
when we freak out you know and so for
the NFL and the NBA to do you know the
NFL with their draft now how you sign
players and you know you have to deal
with social distancing you have to hear
to all that you have to be over-reactive
because you don't want to look back and
say oh no what did i do you know what
did I do how did I caused this this and
this so you have to overreact
but that said any within those
constraints anything you can do that has
any level of normalcy please do do
because we want diversions that's why
coming back and playing an exhibition
game or getting our games played even if
there there's no fans there that's a
sense of normalcy that gives us
something like to your point to divert
our attention to make us feel a little
better so you know what if people want
to argue about who's going to be drafted
by the NFL or the NBA that's a great
thing that's not a bad thing yeah I'm
there with you and I know the people you
know it so it's insensitive that Amari
Cooper is signing a five-year 100
million dollar deal and I'm going I'm
not bothered by it I know I just I I
needed the break I know let me just say
an absolute fact of life when you're
dealing with in perfect information you
make in purpose imperfect decisions and
every decision you make is going to be
wrong at some level to somebody every
single one and knowing that you just
have to make the best decisions that you
can and that's why this is not the time
look I'm not a fan of Donald Trump but
I'm certainly not going to criticize him
I think what he's doing his best and you
know the government's doing their best
our politicians are doing their best and
now is not the time to criticize them
don't be plenty of time for that when
we're on the other side of this and hell
yeah I'll be I'll be throwing I'll be
throwing fire at the
people I don't agree with but now is not
the time now is the time for us to
recognize that you know it's we the
people and we're in this together
there's just it's just wasted energy
just criticizing people right now good
to talk to you mark thanks for joining
us we appreciate it
anytime Dan appreciate it buddy that's
Mark Cuban Mavs owner of course one of
the stars of shark tank